[Music]
Kendra Wilkinson has filed for divorce
from Hank Baskett
after nearly nine years of marriage I
did everything I could
it wasn't good enough
Kendra breaking down on Instagram on
Monday after sources told et's she
decided to end her marriage to the
former NFL player I will always love him
my heart will always remain open for him
I believed in forever I really did
because it's just not meant to be I'm so
scared
what I have to get strong for my kids I
will thank you to all my friends and
family for supporting me at the moment
every little ounce of love helps Kendra
and Hank share two kids eight-year-old
son Hank and three-year-old daughter
Elijah last week a source told Edie
Kendra was spending quality time with
her close friends and focusing on
herself and her kids
amid the split decision quote she feels
broken and has come to terms with the
fact that her relationship with Hank
isn't healthy anymore there was a moment
where I did want to divorce Hank but I
knew everything was gonna be okay in
that route I know it sounds so
complicated but that's wait when
Kendra's been candid about her marriage
problems over the years in 2014 Hank
allegedly cheated on Kendra this isn't
something that you can just fix
overnight I'm still getting answers like
I'm still begging him for answers I hope
this is a happy ending I hope